je suis en train d'expliquer simplement
qu'il y avait eu l'organisation
nécessaire après un an pour fait
d'études sur le terrain
hu
il a fallu parler reste restructuration
en fait les restructurations au sein
dans la martinique
donc en fait je n'ai pas ajouter quoi
que ce soit par rapport à ce que j'ai
dit enfin je crois que j'ai j'ai été
très clair
comme je disais il ya une implantation
nécessaire d'un marche martinique
n'aurait jamais vu le jour si jacky le
courtier n'avait pas été là c'est vrai
ça c'était le temps d'implantation
désormais le mouvement étant implanté
simplement cette compétence là qui fait
partie des statuts que je pourrais vous
en voyez si on voulait d'ailleurs elle
simplement réattribuer parmi les autres
compétences
n'importe quel autre référent en la rue
sur la forme
monsieur le courtier semblent le
découvrir ce soir ça ne semble pas très
fair play fair play je vous pose la
question est-ce que réparer une autre
façon de le lui annoncer par exemple
parce qu'ils semblent le découvrir ce
soir j'ai essayé vous avez essayé je
n'ai rien à ajouter